mais
m
[Musique]
en coton noir compliquer un pays que
j'aime à dire j'ai envie de rire rien ne
peut me retenir que moi qui sont
présentés
[Musique]
williams encore est bon je veux tu sais
pas si mauvais mais le barça parce que
je n'ai pas de temps à perdre - mon
humeur ne te regarde
[Rires]
j'ai autre chose à faire qu'à écouter
plaisanterie je t'ai jamais ils ne
croient pas ils vous croient pas le
pauvre mauvais raconte barre mais le cas
nous valons bien
on va me v13 mon lépi à toi monnaie
si j'en avais un je sentirais tout de
même les vous d'éviter la tête ascaride
de jeu tu me dire ce que tu vois dans
mon bureau
tournez vous s'il vous plaît oh je vois
grand trou à votre habit mais alors
c'est donc free mon habillé trou est
trop bon dieu mais que va dire le grand
yaka
je n'ose pas me présenter devant lui or
quelle affaire mais que fait il
proposait une pièce pour boucher les
trous mais comment faire une réparation
par des années passées de secours a pas
de moi ici pour ce pauvre mosca il est
extra gamme en ridicule où l on bachand
télé mais des avait pavé la vie de votre
cas vous mais le coeur de l'émoi du
style unique lui ai dit ici ça dépasse
mes possibilités soit enfin sauvé ce
seuil à hadj habib ben voilà titillé par
étape at on tiré le gros lot acheté par
bobo mais bon ma fille
je compte 2 à 15 h cup et voilà malgré
lui jeu réservé à ceux toujours très
dangereux pour la fin laissez moi me
concentrer à tabit 103 enfants attia via
cup
et voilà je suis désolé voilà alors
c'est complet n'est ce pas est ce que à
ce que bruxelles est satisfait c'est un
petit tissu besoin de toi je commence à
trouver le temps long
pourvu que bérénice ne m'oublie pas
notre cas je suis choqué je vous dise
ainsi l'église s'il te plaît aux enfants
est un drôle de travail pour un lion
dépêche-toi titus ou e membre des
mauvais c et d vont être le vin oui non
c'est maladroit titus facile à dire du
pt l'enfer c'est ton temps froid a
failli et voilà c'est le morceau de
tissu pendant que je coûts compass très
bien ne bouge plus 1.6 après par la hapa
gauche après droite et c'est terminé
si je lui cette attitude on peut très
vite dès qu'on va il n'y a plus de trous
no mercy mais jamais merci je peux
j'allais voir le grain à la tête tu est
supportable
je rentre chez moi attends je vais te
buter
tant mieux vaut rire tout seul non
préfère ma et après après
et c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]